the jurogan experience well that's
dr carl hart's argument as well he
prefers heroin
yes yes have you been paying attention
to all the controversy about his new
book really interesting it is really
interesting i mean i read it cover to
cover it's great
i love that guy me too he's so brave
like the way he talks about things to
for the guy to be a professor
at columbia and to just be openly
stating
i i enjoy heroin and it makes me feel
good it makes me compassionate
you know and and he he uses pure heroin
he likes to sniff it
it's tremendously brave and i you know i
was working on my show
for such a long time and you're doing it
in isolation and then it comes out and
you're wondering what people
think of it so i was name-searching
myself and saw some reddit thread
of all these people kind of insulting
carl hart and i just felt like
i think the average person doesn't get
it i don't think they understand exactly
how brave carl hart is
because i have traveled around the world
i have interviewed
countless academics i've been in
academic circles throughout my life
drug use of the sort that he describes
is extremely
common it's extremely common but
being honest about it is incredibly rare
and is commendable
and and if more people were like him i
think a lot of these stigmas
would be reduced and i've even heard
people say well how dare he
reduce the stigmas associated with these
things that's cruel
if you reduce the stigmas you're hurting
people they should be stigmatized
no they should not be stigmatized maybe
they shouldn't be encouraged
but if you find yourself in that sort of
situation you shouldn't be ashamed
you should see it as if anything a
medical problem
or a social problem not something that
you need to be hated for
right because we're not we don't hate
people for being alcoholics
right we praise them for their sobriety
like when they get their
90-day chip or whatever they get you
know people
say they don't they look at you like you
know you're you're some sort of a fool
because you couldn't handle alcohol
they go oh he was an alcoholic but he
sobered himself up good for him
oh yeah yeah you know the heroin use
is just so stigmatized and i'm not a
heroin user i haven't used heroin
but i did have a morphine drip once when
i had a
surgery it was awesome oh my god i kept
hammering that thing you press a button
to give you a morphine drip i had knee
surgery
and i was in the hospital and i was on
this perpetual motion machine you ever
seen one of those
because i had an acl reconstruction
arterial
cruciate ligament it's a big injury they
take a piece of your patella tendon
a piece of your shin bone and a piece of
your knee and they open you up and screw
them and drill them in place
pretty [ __ ] painful and so while
you're lying in bed
my knee is on this thing and it's going
like bending
and straightening my knee over and over
and over again and i'm lying in there
and they give you a drip
and anytime you want just press that
button and you get a little drip of
morphine i'm going bang
bang bang bang bang bang it's just
ah i felt so good
i felt so good i was like oh now i get
it
now i know why people like this [ __ ]
morphine's basically heroin right pretty
close
extremely close yeah yeah i get it
morphine
i get it yeah it's probably awesome but
for him you know he's talking about
pure heroin small amounts he understands
it
he's a chemist you know i mean he he
really gets it
you know he's a research scientist you
understand you know he was a
complete straight lace guy wasn't doing
anything until he was in his 30s
yeah i know pretty crazy story it is a
crazy story and what i really appreciate
about what he does is i think there's
a lot of perhaps justified insecurity
in the world of drugs so people have
been
oppressed for such a long time that they
need a justification of some kind
i'm using psychedelics because it's
religious i'm using psychedelics because
it's medical it's a therapy
i'm using psychedelics because it's
traditional it's part of my
religion i'm using psychedelics for this
reason or that reason it's very rare
that people will just stand up and say
i'm using these things
because that's my freedom i don't need
to justify it i don't need to say
that i have chronic back pain and it's
treating it and i should be allowed to
treat my pain
it doesn't matter it's just my choice as
an adult
even if it's bad for me it's my choice
as an adult yeah it needs no
justification
like whiskey yeah i mean whiskey's
celebrated it's on television you can
watch ads for whiskey
during tv shows it's like celebrated
have a glass of whiskey and i like
whiskey but you drink a lot of whiskey
it will
[ __ ] you up and we don't care we we
we're just accustomed to it it's become
a part of our culture
so it's a traditional use it's it's
sanctioned
by the government you get a nice tax
stamp on it and so we're okay with it
but all these patterns
i just described emerged during
prohibition as well yeah
so you so alcohol is prohibited
so you have medical whiskey you have you
get a prescription from the doctor for
whiskey because it's uh it's good for
your nerves
one of our sponsors buffalo trace
they've been around longer than the
united states they've been around since
1773
and they made whiskey during prohibition
they're still running they're the
longest running
distillery in america and they made
whiskey for medicinal purposes
during prohibition which is kind of
hilarious
and of course we see it with cannabis as
well and
i get it i understand why people are
doing this because it remains very
controversial and so you want some kind
of justification but you should remember
at the end of the day that no
justification should be required
and if you get too lost in the
justification you might forget why
you're doing it in the first place
like an analogy that i've been thinking
about for years
like is kind of like a long analogy so
it's gonna be like a one-minute analogy
but like it would be
it would be like if um in the 60s
people started listening to music for
the first time
and they decided that it was
associated with the counter culture
anti-war movement
um some people were listening to music
too loud and causing irreversible damage
to their hearing
and so medical doctors said okay this is
clearly a problem this person is deaf as
a result of listening to music
we've gotta regulate it we've gotta
prohibit it to protect people because
it's a problem and then on top of that
there's an added advantage that because
everyone is going to continue listening
to music
we can selectively prosecute the people
that we want to
because it's a little crime that
everyone is committing and then
that keeps going for years and people
continue listening to music and playing
music and they create their own biases
where they say it's okay to listen to
music it's just
as long as you don't perform it or
record it it's alright as long as you're
just a listener
and then eventually some scientists get
together and they all say that they've
never
listened to music before because if they
had it would somehow
bias their understanding and that would
be terrible so they've never listened to
music before but they've looked at
old pre-prohibition information on music
and they've decided scientifically
that it is in fact very good and can be
used as a medicine
and then everyone embraces it as a
medicine and says oh i just listened to
music today it was so wonderful for my
anxiety it was really fantastic
and that would be great and that would
be good and that would be a way to make
music legal again
but it also would entirely miss the
point that music doesn't have to be
a medicine and to be clear you could do
these studies with music
music is a medicine there is music
therapy i'm sure you could design
a study where music treats
neurodegenerative diseases
or music treats depression i guarantee
it and you could get positive results
and you could then say that music is a
medicine but
so what it doesn't need to be a medicine
right
and i just want people to as as much
as i enjoy this new
medicalization and the decriminalization
that's taking place
i just hope people remember that it
doesn't need to be any of those things
and this history of justification is
ultimately something that we
are doing because we're afraid afraid
that
to acknowledge the fact that we should
be free to do whatever we want
regardless of whether or not it's good
yes yeah well said so i mean you could
use that for anything right you could
say that about exercise
you can say that about running you like
to run well there's been medical studies
that show that running is bad for your
knees you should stop running
oh yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] like we should
outlaw crossfit you know many people
[ __ ] up their back and tear shoulders
for crossfit well we need to stop
crossfit you can say that about anything
and the problem is
a lot of what you get when you have
people telling people to not do things
is people that don't have any experience
in those things telling people
not to do them and whether they're drugs
or whether they're
physical activity or whether they're
there's a lot of different things that
people do
that you could racing cars you could
deem them detrimental
and i am a proponent of freedom and i
don't think there's any all-knowing
all-seeing being that's wiser that
understands
the correct way for all human beings to
move forward in life and
the correct decisions to make there's no
father figure there's no godlike
human being out there that can guide us
the correct way that it's not
there's pros and cons to everything that
you could abuse
almost everything you do you know like
if you if you show that people
if they jog a little bit every day it's
actually turns out to be good for you
but ultra marathons we have to outlaw
because uh these people are they're
getting uh rhabdomyolysis they're
they're they're pissing out diet coke
and they look terrible and they're dying
they're like no like you got to be able
to do whatever you want to do you're a
human being
and you are finite no matter what it's
not like if you die
the uh entire world suffers some
irreversible
loss and millions of people starve to
death because you decide to run 100
miles that's no it's
you and your life do what you want
whether it's smoking marijuana or
running a hundred miles
or doing whatever the [ __ ] you want and
unless we embrace that
we're going to see more of this nanny
state nonsense
that we've been dealing with since
prohibition in this country
and we're dealing with it right now
there's a lot of things that will never
kill you
that are illegal cannabis being one of
the big ones because that's the most
preposterous one
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience